in the last video we figured out how to
construct a unit normal vector to a
surface and so now we can use that back
in our original surface integral to try
to simplify a little bit or at least
give us a clue of how we can calculate
these things and also think about
different ways to represent this type of
a surface integral so if we just
substitute what we came up as our normal
vector our unit normal vector right here
we will get
we will get so once again it's the
surface integral of f
f
dot and f dot all of this business right
over here and i'm going to write it all
in white just so it doesn't take me too
much time so the partial of r with
respect to u crossed with the partial of
r with respect to v
over the magnitude of the same thing
partial of r with respect to u crossed
with the partial of r with respect to v
and now we've played with d s a lot we
know that another way to write ds and i
gave the intuition hopefully for that
several videos ago when we first
explored what a surface integral was all
about we know that ds
we know that ds is it can be represented
as the magnitude of the partial of r
with respect to u crossed with the
partial of r with respect to v d u
d v and obviously the d d u d v it could
be written as d v d u you could write it
as d a a little chunk of area in the u v
plane or in the u v domain and actually
since now this integral is in terms of
uv we're no longer taking a surface
integral we're now taking a double
integral over the uv domain so you could
say kind of a region in uv so this is
gonna i'll say r to say that it's a
region in in the uv plane that we're now
thinking about but there's probably a
huge or there should be or i'm guessing
there's a huge simplification that's
popping out at you right now we're
dividing by the magnitude of the cross
product of these two vectors and then
we're multiplying by the by the
magnitude of the cross product of these
two vectors those are just scalar
quantities you divide by something and
multiply by something well that's just
the same thing as multiplying or
dividing by one so these two characters
cancel out and our integral simplifies
to
the double integral over that region the
corresponding region in the uv plane
of f
of
our vector field f dotted with this
cross product this is going to give us a
vector right over here that's going to
give us a vector that's it gives us
actually a normal vector and then you
divide by its magnitude it gives you a
unit normal vector so this
you're going to you're going to take the
dot product of f with
r
the partial of r with respect to u
crossed with the partial of r with
respect to v
d u d v
d
u let me scroll over to the right a
little bit d u
d v and we'll see in a few few videos
from now that this is essentially how we
go about actually calculating these
things if you have a parametrization you
can then get everything in terms of a
double integral in terms of uv
this way now the last thing i want to do
is explore another way that you'll see a
surface integral like this written it
all comes from really writing this part
in a different way but hopefully gives
you a little bit more intuition of what
this thing is even saying so i'm just
going to rewrite i'm going to rewrite
this chunk right over here i'm just
going to rewrite that chunk
and i'm going to use slightly different
notation because it'll hopefully help
make a little bit more sense so the
partial of r with respect to u i can
write as
the partial of r with respect to u and
we're taking the cross product let me
make my u's a little bit more u-like so
we don't confuse them with v's and we're
taking the cross product of that with
the partial of r
with respect to v so very small changes
in our vector in our in our
parameterization right here our position
vector given a small change in v very
small changes in the vector given a
small change in u and then we're
multiplying that times d u dv
we're multiplying that
times d u
d u
dv now d v d u and dv are just scalar
quantities these are they're
infinitesimally small so but for the
sake of this argument you can just view
that they're not vectors they're just
scalar quantities and so you can
essentially
include them
if you know if you have the cross
product if you have you know a
cross b
times some scalar value i don't know x
you could rewrite this as x times a
cross b
or you could write this as a
cross
x times b because x is just a scalar
value it's just a number so we could do
the same thing over here we can rewrite
all of this business as and i'm going to
group the d u with where we have the
partial of
with respect to u in the denominator and
i'll do the same thing with the v's and
so you'll get
you will get the partial of r
with respect to u
times d u times that scalar so that'll
give us a vector and we're going to
cross that we're going to cross that
with the partial of r with respect to v
partial of r with respect to e
dv
d
dv
now these might look notationally like
two different things but that just comes
from the necessity of of when we take
partial derivatives to say oh no this is
you know this this vector function is
defined in it's a function of multiple
variables and this is taking a
derivative with respect to only one of
them so this is how much does our vector
change when you have a very small change
in u but this is also an infinitesimally
small change in u over here we're just
using slightly different notation so for
the sake and this is a little bit
loosey-goosey mathematics but it'll
hopefully give you the intuition for why
this thing can be written in a different
way
these are essentially the same quantity
so if you divide by something and
multiply by something you can cancel
them out if you divide by something
multiply some by something you can
cancel them out and all you're left with
then
all you're left with is the differential
of r and since we lost the information
that it's in the u direction all right
here the differential of r in the u
direction i don't want to get you get
the notation confused this is just a
differential this is just how much r
change this is not the partial
derivative of r with respect to u this
right over here is how much does our
change given per unit change per small
change in u this is just says a
differential in the direction of in i
guess as u changes this is the diff how
much that infinitely small change that
just r changes this isn't change in r
with respect to change in u and we're
going to cross that and we're going to
cross that with the partial of r
the partial of r in the v direction now
this right over here let's just
conceptualize this and this goes back to
our original visions of what a surface
integral was all about
if we're on a surface and i'll draw a
surface right let me draw another
surface i won't use the one that i had
already drawn on if we draw a surface
and for a very small change in u and
we're not going to think about the rate
we're just thinking about the the kind
of the change in r you're going in that
direction so if this thing if that thing
looks like this this is actually kind of
a distance moved on the surface because
it's just it's not remember this isn't
the derivative this is the differential
so it's just a small change along the
surface that's that over there
and that this is a small change when you
change v so it's also a change along the
surface when you take the cross product
of these two things you get a vector
that is orthogonal you get a vector that
is normal to the surface so it is normal
normal too the surface and its magnitude
its magnitude and we saw this when we
first learned about cross products its
magnitude is equal to the area that's
kind of that is defined by these two
vectors
so its magnitude
is
equal
to
area so in a lot of ways you can really
think of it you really could think of it
as a normal a unit normal vector times d
s and so the way that we would i guess
notationally do this is we can call this
because this is kind of a ds but it's a
vector version of the ds over here this
is just an area right over here this is
just a scalar value but now we have a
vector that points normally from the
surface but its its magnitude is the
same thing as that ds that we were just
talking about so we can call this thing
right over here we can call this ds and
the key difference here is this is a
vector now
so we'll call it d s with a little
vector over it to know that this is this
thing this isn't the scalar ds that is
just concerned with the area but when
you view things this way we just saw we
just saw that this entire thing
simplifies to ds then our whole surface
integral our whole surface integral can
be rewritten instead of writing it like
this we can write it as
we can write it as the surf the
integral or the surface integral
those
integral signs were too fancy the
surface integral of
of f
dot instead of saying a normal vector
times the scalar quantity that little
chunk of area on the surface we can now
just call that the vector differential d
ds and i want to make it clear these are
two different things this is a vector
this is how we would this is essentially
what we're calling it this right over
here is a scalar times a normal vector
so these are three different ways of
really representing the same thing and
in different contexts you will see
different things depending on what i
guess the author or whoever is trying to
communicate is trying to communicate
this right over here is the one that
we'll use most frequently as we actually
try to calculate these surface integrals